welcome to this video playing chess
dream from the US let's see while the
sloth for a change what could I do well
in app I always played a 6cm in former
times the chip and ankle I didn't have
bad results with it I am I rarely play
that nowadays but there's no particular
reason for that I was just trying to to
do new things with the new oil Bhogle
for the book project and stuff but the
Chevin encode sloth is a very reliable
opening quick b8 yeah this is a good
maneuver I think it covers the e5 square
so it cannot easily play 95 and it's
it's on b8 to allow a retreat to c7 and
stay out of the sea file so we ate us a
bit better than putting it on c7 yeah of
course at some very solid type of
position what should I do here
what possible plan could be still
beehive beehive intending to take and
exposes bishop on be too maybe I'd like
to do something in this position not
just stay put I can place instead slow
improving moves through create h6 stuff
like that doesn't really lead to much
you had the trade I don't know the trait
I don't mind the only thing that always
needs to be considered is the c6 square
that's a bit weak of course but well I
don't mind that if you okay now
LightSquared bishop sigh i like to
exchange and now maybe queen bee 7 yeah
this looks good I'll wait wait a moment
here yeah yeah I can click and go 95
after that but I like to cover seasick
simply play Roxy adium you can't you
can't have it all yeah it still looks
very very comfortable like comfortable
position it's very symmetrical but I
have the better Bishop here on the
success bishop on b2 is not it's not
really am a great piece there should be
four maybe I can provoke something
trying to take here I couldn't play 90
form may be 94 yeah well okay let's
let's see what he's doing it's um it's
still very solid i'm not saying why does
in trouble i mean it's just that i'm out
of the woods in terms of having any any
problems hmm yeah interesting should i
take on d to it weakens the dark squares
I shouldn't I don't really think I
should take a three was a good good
thing to provoke I mean it's it's a
target you please put a pawn on a dark
square that's good with the bishop and
Bishop a three on white spot is never
possible now I know Bishop a3 is covered
but if I regroup or something then
Bishop e3 gets interesting again yeah 95
ok this might going 496 yeah come on
just take it keep it simple you know the
thing is I would like to get the rooks
off but I mean on Roxie to is always
playing Queen see to this is also why i
went with this year to go light b6 so
then i can always exchange on c2 like
Roxy to Quincy to looks the aid as
possible then you need to improve the
end with small steps nothing spectacular
possible here oh no this is good news
some weakening light squares a bit more
I'd like to prevent f5 though I'll make
mac ecology for or is this insane now on
g4 f5 it's not really threatening much
ok no as this is not a problem
note that if he tries to play um okay
and now i can take on c2 if you place
the night i would also have 95 to FY now
I get the rocks off of course yeah I go
Bishop c5 to attack that isn't this
inconvenient for him come a bit in a bit
but now I can you can still play on a
move like night f1
hmm he will hold he will play Quincy one
anyway I don't need to take now on CL C
2 I mean I wonder if I should regroup
the bishop here I don't know very
difficult we should be for a three is
hanging note that this a three more from
madame the slight weakness yeah i can go
queen bee six but what it is actually
doing yeah maybe maybe still now now
Bishop t4s is threatened as I cannot
take here should I should avoid that my
night only seven I need to activate the
night this is really really necessary to
to get to get anywhere near maybe 2i now
maybe to see six or something yeah let's
let's take that get night against bishop
okay enter here and then knight c6 my
dark squares are weak as well but I
don't see how we enters that ok yeah
this is a comfortable endgame not sure
if i can win but it's it's comfortable
with the spawns on on dark squares app i
probably I probably have hard time to
win but still
need to check get the King over here c5
I just stay put f5 I just I just stay
put yeah just putting it down I'm going
to d5 with the night yes it's very very
difficult to to do anything in this
position now I can go to see six maybe
and then Knight to f5 I don't think I'm
not sure if I can zoom on Ymir oh yeah
no okay and I forgot that he gets h5
time morning check 17 seconds check
check what an ok I will win this on time
probably but not a good game I mean I
had a good position but draw offered
white forfeits on time now I offered to
draw but it was so down long time
couldn't really accept it anymore yeah i
was playing to win to him well at the
end even got in trouble how does this
happen
let's let's check I mean around here it
looked really okay I shouldn't lose
really yeah he can go yeah here may be
here yeah well he can go to g5 I need to
prevent that probably knight Knight to
g5 again yeah etc I mean he's got three
ports on dark square so I thought maybe
I can do something but yeah well this
physicist was too ambitious I mean here
it gets tricky okay it seems I can still
draw with 94 but you know I only now
really realize that I'm losing the pawn
and this is probably a very tricky
probably probably a draw the booth good
play but check I am I still try it
subjects but check it sir yeah this is
losing no but okay I only a couple of
seconds and didn't really know what to
do offer a draw we know time or whatever
yeah yeah yes I thought I I have more
chances in this position with all pawns
on light squares and he's got some some
structural problems but the space
advantage is good enough to draw okay
thanks for watching